Today we are going to work on
CUDA and compilation stuff.
The uh the goal here of the day,
well, there are a few different goals
really.
Hang on a moment.
There kind of two sides to this, right?
There's the CUDA environments bit and
then there is the uh torch compile bit.
we have this profiling bit from before.
What's your opinion on arrest? Hate it.
Hate the language.
Especially
you can make an argument like you can
make a decent argument for for embedded
system stuff, but for like the stuff I'm
doing, it's just completely stupid.
Makes your life uh a complete pain in
the ass to protect you from a relatively
small class of bugs that like are not
even really major problems.
Um, for the stuff I do in RL, with one
possible exception that I'm looking into
at the moment, it's pretty stupid.
Uh, Jax forces you to write absolutely
terrible code
because
So essentially there's this decision
that was made that it makes it easier to
implement a library like Jax if you make
an assumption that's not technically
required by the hardware and it makes
you write terrible code. It gets a bit
more detailed than that but it's just I
have not tried to be fair. I have not
tried to write puffer lib quality code
in JS. It might be possible,
but it definitely gets in your way.
At the moment, I'm trying as hard as I
can to keep puffer lib in Torch because
it's just a better overall library uh
with more users as well.
The only thing I'm not entirely sure
about with Torch is the compile times um
for like if you're trying to complic uh
compile large chunks of code, the
compile times are starting to bother me.
The only thing I'm not sure about yet,
I've run a few Perf tests and so far I
have not like Jax does not seem to be
faster as anything like that.
Nigrad's cool. I'm probably don't agree
with all the technical decisions, but
it's an awesome project overall. Uh
there's not really any reason for me to
look at it yet, though, because so far
their Nvidia back end they say is like a
few times slower than Torch. Um and it's
going to be a couple years before they
catch up.
because it doesn't force you to write
terrible code.
Like go read any Jack's code. It's
terrible.
It's like the worst aspects of
functional and object-oriented
programming blended together into
something that's somehow even worse than
either.
this is still not good usage right here.
Right?
you get to 44 T flops.
Well, okay, hang on. If we model the
hidden size,
Gymnasium is a way older project, dude.
And gymnasium is not even a training
library. It's a freaking spec that like
everything uses.
Puffer is the fastest growing RL RL
library as far as I'm aware right now.
We're already like we're already doing
it, man. Look, we have the chart on the
website.
It's literally just keep doing what I'm
doing and keep shipping the next few
updates.
This is when I started working on it
full-time.
If I can actually make this next update
work, it'll make everything so much
faster and everything will just get so
so so much better.
It's going to be hard technical work.
Hence the title for today.
Mobile multi- aent systems. I have no
idea what the hell that means.
Mobile multi-agent systems. Well, multi-
aent
I probably have the my PhD is probably
the most multi- aent of any of
anybody's. I don't think anybody's done
anything like neural MMO.
I don't know what mobile means in that.
and perform an RL code inject. Oh,
you're the author of that.
So, Carlos, the the argument basically
for
using Jacks for training in my mind is
defensible. The argument against using
jacks for environments is that you just
compare the code like compare writing
the code in C to compare writing the
code in JS. It's always simpler in C.
You just write arbitrary loops and
conditionals and it's even faster
anyways
because Jax is like doing really heavily
branching ops
in JS is no bueno, right?
I am actually starting to play around
with doing uh CUDA just like pure CUDA
and see how that goes because if you
keep CUDA very simple, you're basically
just writing C. And in fact, I might
even be able to have it support C and
CUDA backends with the same code.
yeah the main beef I have with the JX
M's thing Carlos just to put it clear is
that so what happened right is that RL
was doing all this work on like Atari
and stuff and I started trying I spent
multiple years trying to push the field
of RL towards more complex and
interesting environments and even we got
a few of them but then Jacks pushed it
back the other way so for the sake of
performance you have these M's and Jacks
But then because the M's are injected,
it's really hard to write complex
environments. So like you get minitar
and stuff which are these super super
simple dumb down environments and that
just kills the field, right? Because
like you can't just revert RL to simpler
tasks, right? Then everybody just stops
caring. You need to go towards higher
per and more complex tasks. And the way
to do that is at least what we've found
so far is you had to rewrite the
vectorization stack and everything um to
and actually support like not dropping
your performance. But once you do that,
you can get stuff running super fast
even just on CPU in really simple code.
Swarm robotics.
Well, no. We don't have good
environments for that, Ronaldo. But like
you can write an N for that or port an N
for that to Puffer and our trainer will
be better than anything else out there
because nobody else has a remotely as
fast trainer as Puffer.
One train agent against past self. How
can load predisposed at Spencer or at
like Lionheart or whatever his user is
in the Discord? He's working on that
now.
Neural Mammo is a swarm though. Yeah.
It's just that's purely just like Yeah,
we haven't bothered to port like a
specific swarm robot. Actually, we do
technically. We have a drone end. Yeah.
Wait, we we actually we have multiple
drone ends and there are a couple guys
in the Discord that are running it on
like real hardware now as well. I take
that back. Yeah, we totally do. We don't
have like quadriped or whatever, but you
know, go ahead and make an end if it'll
work.
Is it available right now?
It's got to be a public dev branch
somewhere. He said he's going to try to
have a working implementation by this
weekend of it.
So, the thing is it's a it's a bit more
complicated than just loading an
opponent, right? Like he's trying to do
the thing from the Dota paper. Yeah,
Spencer.
This is 83.
Let me just see how high this goes real
quick.
139.
Okay. Interesting.
The heck just happened?
There we go.
Easiest workound for that if it's still
not available.
You just like hack uh the pufferell
file, right? Our trainer is a single
file implementation. You just modify
that to load in like an extra policy for
the eval loop.
You'd probably want to like um make sure
that the vectorization is not doing like
double buffering or whatever. You can
just predict the uh
the agent indices.
55 T flops. Is this right? 155.
What are we supposed to be able to get?
This is 82 in double. Oh no, 82 in
float.
Welcome everyone.
I'm playing around with a little bit of
profiling and then we're going to try to
apply some of what we find to the uh the
trainer.
150. Okay. So it's it is the same here.
So we are getting basically this number,
right? We're getting the FP32 accumulate
number.
Why are we getting this number? Does
anybody know where like
I guess the easiest thing would just be
to try to like crank everything up and
see if we can go higher, right?
This will lag me a bit.
Hopefully I don't know it.
Okay. 157. So, we're definitely getting
Oops. And I got to not keep doing that
because that dropped my OBS for a
second.
But uh so we definitely are stuck at the
that number.
I don't know why they give you that like
why that's your master's thesis project
if you don't already have experience in
that cuz like you're going to have to
build something and that's going to be a
pretty sophisticated sim.
It's like you either have to know what
you're doing and build something or use
something existing and spend a really
long time fiddling with it.
Yeah. So, we're getting this
Interesting.
Oh, I think that torch has this
disabled, right?
Yeah. Yeah, there is something about
torch being weird with this.
Yeah, the thing is Pi Bullet's basically
useless because of how slow it is.
But yeah, you can use Majoko or Pi
Bullet or one of those and then you'll
get something that's too slow to be
useful or at least like at the at the
least too slow to be reasonably useful,
right? A lot of people do research on
really slow M and uh the sad truth of it
is you just waste years of your life
like waiting for [ __ ] to run and not
being able to do your experiments fast
enough.
Trust me, I know.
So, um, jacks for M's that are naturally
just straight array operations, like if
you are naturally just doing physics ops
that are very easily expressed in pure
array manipulations, that's actually not
bad.
It's like branching logic. typical
conditional stuff in Sims where Jax gets
to be dumb.
Allow
wait. If reduced precision,
intermittent
Cool. Have some cool people in the uh in
the chat. That's fun.
Has anybody actually ever seen a 4090
get the expected single prec uh
precision?
Okay. Okay. So, I mean it looks to me
like at least we are getting the
expected.
We are at least getting the expected 16
bit with 32-bit accum.
And then if I go back uh what is this?
So 128
down from 157. What do we get?
O,
Is this a batch? Wait, can we get this
with like 32?
Can I get around this with batch size?
Physics is just an array with minimal
logic. Yeah, then Carlos, that's totally
reasonable.
You can do the same thing with freaking
torch tensors then
bit irritating but this is at least way
better than before.
Yeah, this was the torch end that we
Have
you
ever
Cuz Jack Jax is like default. You jet
everything. Torch you actually have to
use compile for stuff cuz torch is like
torch has a lot of optimizations for
eager mode to be at least pretty good.
compiled. H interesting cuz I've been
running like perf tests with Jax and it
doesn't seem like it's better.
Also, you don't have to write the
environment in the same language as the
uh the trainer either. You can pass
tensors back and forth between um torch
and jacks without having to copy them
off device
just a cast pretty much. I think
this model wasn't learning speedy
pointer nets.
You're gonna have to just go profile.
What part of your thing is slow, Jess?
Like how many actions are you um giving
it to choose between?
like that.
forces.
Carlos, I am pretty excited in general
about like material science plus RL
64. You should be able to make decently
fast,
I'd imagine.
Okay. So, this is
Yeah, something has happened then with
my install.
Yeah. Yeah. This is the new torch
version. That's weird.
Inductor raised.
So Jess, we want to fully compile the
train loop and we're also going to try
what happens if the end is CUDA.
That's basically what we're going to try
to do, Jess, actually. But that's not
the hard part, believe it or not. Like
the CUDA M part is going to be annoying,
but like I'm very confident I can make
that stuff work. The annoying part is
actually the compile stuff.
So, if you all want to help me with
that, be my guest. Um, let me use the
restroom real quick and then I'm going
to get my first set in for the day.
Since today is hard uh hard programming
today, today is also hard deadlifting
Oh
man.
Holy hell.
Hard set.
That's 355 for five raw though. That's
not bad.
Probably just do triples for the rest of
today. I got my uh my set of five in.
I'm happy with that.
You do not do heavy deadlifts.
Pretty hard to get that exhausted
with seemingly so little work in just
about any other way.
man.
Okay.
All right. What's What's going on with
this? Why Why is standard bad alle
[ __ ] Um,
five is pretty high up there, right?
It's going to be like plus 10% now.
at 400. Okay. So, that's actually
that's pretty pretty close. I don't
actually want to do a 1 RM, but that
should in theory be pretty close to four
plate.
So, then the goal will be like I
probably need to be able to triple 405
in order to be able to one rep it like
comfortably without it being max effort.
My best was um when I weighed like 187.
So that's almost 20 lbs heavier than I
am now. My highest absolute weight was
410 for two reps. That's with belt and
straps though.
Okay. What? Can somebody like What's
going on here? I had this working before
this. Was I doing this on um on Puffer
Max?
I don't think I was doing this on Puffer
Max, right?
You know, I wasn't doing this on Puffer
Max,
so something's got screwed up.
What's the right torch?
Backend inductor.
Well, now this is obnoxious, isn't it?
What version of torch do I have on the
container?
That's a good thing to go check cuz
otherwise we're going to get stuck doing
dumb stuff for a while.
I see. So it just has CUDA 128. So this
will actually grab
recent version. Cool. Um,
here's what we're going to do.
Next little bit here, I am going to
I'm going to build out a miniature
version of the puffer train and ford
loop with the LSTM. And I'm going to see
if I can get that to compile. That's
going to be the goal.
Yeah, that's what we're going to do.
and then we will try to get in
probably three deadlift sets.
Maybe I'll do three. Yeah, three or
four. And then I'll do some accessory.
Those are the two things for today.
What are you doing? Would love to get an
elevator pitch. Y one sec. So
those are two different questions. So,
Pufferlib is a very fast reinforcement
learning library for RL. Uh, the project
as a whole is just my comprehensive
effort to fix everything that was wrong
with the field when I was a PhD student.
Um, we have training up to millions of
steps per second. We have ultraast
environments. We've made it really easy
to write fast environments. We have
better hyperparameter tuning sweeps. We
have better learning algorithms. Just
tons and tons of general advancement. Uh
we do a few things professionally as
well. Puffer is a private lab, but all
of our stuff is free and open source.
And what I'm doing at the moment is I'm
working on the next version of the
library and I'm working on some pretty
serious performance optimizations
because Puffer is already way faster
than anything else out there. But if you
do the napkin math, like we're nowhere
near as fast as you should be able to
get the hardware uh with a fully
optimized implementation. So my goal is
to get within some reasonable factor of
what the hardware can actually output in
the the next version of the library. And
to do that I have to fight torch pretty
heavily because I am optimizing training
for much smaller models than people will
typically bottle to uh bother to
optimize stuff for. So there like a ton
of additional layers of stuff that I
have to deal with for that. You know
people always talk about how difficult
it is to perf optimize large models. you
have the exact same thing when you try
to perf optimize really small models.
What are you running on to get what are
the GPUs behind you? Well, what I'm
running on right here, this is a desktop
with a 4090 in it. And then behind me
are you can see there's a row of
desktops each with a 4090 in them. We've
got a couple multiGPU boxes with several
4090s. And then there's one box with a
5090 in there.
As for what? Oh, but that's that was it.
What are my jobs running on? What am I
running on? I'm running on coffee.
Well, the complete answer would be
coffee hard style and deadlifts,
Well, it depends what you mean by large
tryh hard. Like RL really does not scale
the same way with model size as other
stuff does. Uh especially if you're
measuring by the right thing. So like
our models are typically anywhere from
100,000 up to a few million parameters.
It's a little bit tricky because like if
I wanted to optimize stuff for 20,000
parameter models, I'd have to go even
crazier. Like at 20,000 parameters, you
shouldn't even be using torch. I think
that's a little bit excessive, right?
Like I don't think it really makes sense
for us to try super hard to optimize
stuff below
like 128 hidden dim basic like 100k um
parameter models.
But it is actually meaningful to
optimize down to like the hundred to few
hundreds of thousands regime because uh
you can do a lot of research in that
regime and stuff needs to be fast
because uh the basically the difference
between having stuff optimized and not
optimized at that level is you having to
wait you know an hour per an hour every
time you want to run a full hyperparam
sweep or like it's technically feasible
that we could get hyperparameter sweeps
down to uh like minutes, right? You can
imagine running several hundred
experiments in just a few minutes. That
would let you do dramatically different
and better research.
Oh yeah, you but the thing is like
greater than 500 mil. Do you know how
big the Dota model is? The model that
beat Dota or top pros at Dota is 168
million parameters. RL just totally does
not scale the same way.
like most valuable problems out there,
most like uh RL problems out there are
way simpler than Dota.
And it's mostly a matter of how do we
just make RL stable enough to solve them
without needing a worldass team and like
two or three years to work on the
problem
Jack Marl. Yeah, Puffer's faster.
Jax is generally bad for ends.
Also, the Jack's code is just awful,
awful to deal with.
The only reason I could potentially see
this having to be done in Jax, what I'm
doing here, uh, if I discover that there
is truly no way around for compile times
being as bad as they are for, um, full
loop compilation, then I might have to
go to that. But we will see.
Yeah, it's kind of funny how puffer is
literally puffer in eager mode, like
torch eager mode is faster than
everything else out there
for like a except for like a couple
single purpose really niche libraries.
totally different thing. Try hard like
RL on LM is like baby mode.
the inter the interaction problems
they're solving are like they're hard
problems but they're not hard because of
the same reasons that make actual RL
problems hard.
Like go try to make an LLM play Dota.
Like we have very very clear empirical
evidence that if you have fast
simulators and you have a ton of compute
like the sizes of models that you should
expect to want to be training with RL
are just tiny compared to uh supervised
learning.
Yeah, we do basically everything in RL
but LLMs. Like RL is a very large space
outside of LLM.
In fact, I'd argue it's the more
interesting space because you basically
can't do anything with RL on LLMs unless
you're behind closed doors in a lab with
a ton of GPUs where we can do awesome
research that can go straight onto
product straight into scientific
research and other fields and stuff and
we can do it at home. We're not compute
constrained at all.
Thanks for the talk. Thank you.
And keep on this optim.
I will admit though, Torch Compile is
very, very obnoxious to deal with.
You know what? I bet it is. I bet it's
this stupid thing.
Uh, let me explain this. So basically my
plan is one make crackout RL so that our
RL is basically not this janky thing
that's kind of fiddly and takes a lot of
tweaking right so get really stable sane
RL with good visibility good an
analytics good automatic optimization
all that um and then uh basically
co-adapt a material science sim to be
better suited for RL you know you
wouldn't design a sim the exact exact
same way if it were going to be used for
press button, see what happens versus
for RL and then try to start optimizing
for new materials.
And part of optimizing sim for this,
right, would mean there's speed
optimization involved with that. There's
like what corners can we cut and still
get good outcome. There's multi-level
verification. Um, there's probably going
to be actually some I have some ideas
for modifications to the core RL
algorithm that will require simulation
level modifications as well take full
advantage of. So there are a whole bunch
of different things we can do with this.
The idea generally though, if you want
to see like why this is a good idea,
think of it this way. RL fundamentally
changes the way that you think about and
use simulation as a tool. That's the key
because it's intelligent simulation,
right? It's simulation that you can tell
what you want the outcome to be and
optimize for that outcome instead of
just saying this is a sim, press a
button, see what happens.
[Music]
It depends what you define a task as,
right?
It's mostly a semantic issue, right?
I can tell you to walk and chew gum and
I can say walk and chew gum is one task
or I can say it's two tasks.
Oh no, it's discreet.
We have a multi-discrete M spaces but
neural MMO3 is intentionally for
simplicity. Uh it's designed such that
the action space is a single single
discrete.
So it's super easy to use.
What else? Healing loss. So, Jess, we
need more experiments. Whoops.
YouTube music. Um, so we need to do more
experiments. We have the whole like
other ones, other uh dozen plus M's to
deal with. But I kind of just the way
that I work is I kind of just work on
whatever I feel like working on on any
given day as long as it's in the top few
things that need to get done for the
next release. And at the moment I feel
like working on this side of it because
in my mind uh 40 is going to be like
major PF optimizations and polish. It's
going to be the largest ever data set of
RL experiments released and then
constellation the visualizer that lets
you play with them and get some insights
and as well as like a write up with some
cool insights we find. Um, and because
at the moment I'm basically confident in
the outcome of uh polish. I'm confident
in the outcome of constellation and of
the experiments. The only thing that's
less certain right now, like pretty much
the last couple remaining questions are
around Perf optimization. But that's
what I'm working on now
because as soon as I figure this out,
then there's basically there will be no
more outstanding questions
um for the rest of the update and it
will just be a matter of getting the
work done. And then once that's done,
right, then it's a lot easier for me to
structure my work because then I just
like, you know, basically set up two
week work blocks until it's done.
Something like that. Whereas when
there's this uncertainty, it's like way
harder for me to pin down when stuff is
going to be done, what I need to be
prioritizing. I try to get that done
first.
models and MS if you're going to try to
circumvent
uh we don't really care about backwards
compatibility for trained models
though cuz you can just retrain uh M's
and stuff it's going to be fine like
we're not going to we're not going going
to go break ocean or something like that
obviously.
And this is not really circumventing
PyTorch mostly like this is this is
basically just hacking on their compile
to try to get the whole train loop to
compile. Uh it's kind of obnoxious
because this is one of the things that I
can genuinely admit should be uh easier
the way that Jax does it. Um but then
you have to use Jax which is like gross.
So, I'm basically what I'm doing right
now is I'm trying to see if we can at
least get something good in Torch. And
I'm doing right here. This is a
standalone like simpler version of of
Puffers code. And if I can get this to
work and the flop utilization and stuff
looks good, we'll proceed with this.
Otherwise, we'll have to have a hard
think about whether the train loop needs
to go to jacks, which I really would
prefer not to do, but you never know.
I'm still going to say like one in eight
chance that this ends up having to go to
jacks. I doubt it, but we'll see.
like eggs. But eggs are good. I like
eggs. I don't like jacks.
Ever had the realization you're eating
eggs?
What?
I What the [ __ ] is that supposed to
mean?
calling someone a a uh
a vegetarian in Chinese is literally an
insult.
Oh, there more of them. We have a couple
more PRs to merge later.
Right now, there are two puffers in
here.
You can play with them.
This one's funny because this one likes
to hang out down low, but if you put a
star in the way, it'll like come up to
just not like it'll come up to eat it
just a little tiny bit. But like if you
put one down here, it's not going to
come up unless it thinks it has to like
the other one's too close.
130 WP. I'm Nah, I'm not that fast.
It's Super Maven.
Yeah, like 90ish.
I get slowed down a bunch because I I
type very slightly wrong and I make
errors because of it.
Fun fact, when I first started to type,
like everybody thought I wasn't going to
be able to use computer because I typed
eight WPM.
I actually learned to type playing MMOs.
That was the only thing that worked.
Yeah, notebooks are awful.
I actually am genuinely genuinely at a
point now where um
I think Python hurt
AI more than it helped.
It's really just not a good like one
Python is not a good language to do
everything in.
It's just really not.
All right. So, this is still zero T
flops.
Not good.
Um,
go is like okay
from what I've seen of it.
digit is coming. They have optional
typing in Python. It sucks.
I don't want typing if it doesn't make
it fast.
Whoops. That's a slow benchmark.
Very slow benchmark.
So, Carlos, the closest thing to that
would be like Syon.
Syon, but actually good would be nice.
actually. Um,
Mojo started to get some of the typing
like typed versus untyped stuff correct
and then they like smuggled a bunch of
dumb rust and [ __ ] into uh into it.
But you basically what you want is you
just want something that lets you get as
low level as C and as high level as
Python like pretty effortlessly without
having to go through an obnoxious
binding layer and without killing
compile times. That's what you'd want.
But like in my mind, giving up some of
the highle stuff is
completely acceptable, right? Like most
of the highle stuff, people just end up
using it to write god-awful code. So
like
there are a few things that I wouldn't
want to do in straight C.
Um, string processing comes to mind. is
just being really obnoxious.
But I'd be way happier being closer to
that than closer to the Python.
Yeah, Jess. So, Syon,
it was a decent intermediary, but once
you have a good bind system, uh, you're
better off just writing straight C.
Syonthon has compile bugs. It has like
annoyingly slow compile times. Um, it's
like a weird intermediary where you
can't like you can't cleanly,
it's like annoying to intentionally go
lower or high level. You're kind of
always in the in the middle. Uh, and I
didn't get native C speed out of it
completely either.
Look, in my mind, the language problem
is just not going to get solved. And
CUDA is basically C anyways, so you may
as well just write C.
Okay, something's wrong with B float.
Lovely. Well, we can at least do Yes.
Okay. So, we get 30 t flops out of this
with compile. Without compile, we get
Let's see what a difference it makes.
It's funny seeing stuff like this cuz
like I definitely am not I get tired
just like anyone else and when I get
tired I crash hard.
Oh, that's beautiful.
That is beautiful.
This is not what we want, right? Not at
all.
Yeah, that's not going to be worth
anything.
Good thing we ran this test.
What's up with this
Well, you see the problem, right? Like
we don't want to have
tiny little T flops
test here.
Okay. 76 mil forward though,
right? So this little net here
we are at 76 mil forward and that's in
eager mode.
Compile on. Well, without compile on the
thing is we can also just do um we can
go BF-16
without compile.
Okay. So, that gets us some T flops.
Yeah. Can I do compile now that I fixed
that bug?
So, cool. We get from 39 to 56,
right?
Uh,
well, you couldn't sell Puffer Lib
because that's an open-source library.
It would be Puffer AI the company,
which realistically would mean that they
would want me to be involved because you
wouldn't just buy the entity without
wanting me with it. And then that would
highly depend on like for what purpose,
what terms, etc.
It would either have to be like a big
number plus I basically get to do what
I'm doing now but much more effectively
or a really big number such that in a
couple years I come back to what I'm
doing now but much more effectively with
funding with well like unlimited
funding.
But that's not exactly what I'm looking
to do at the moment, right?
Ever succeeded. That's actually like one
of those crazy topics that I'd be happy
to go spend a bunch of time researching.
And I think I'm actually in a better
position to figure that out than the top
labs are.
Like that's like something you could
very easily test
in like a core RL setting, right?
Crypt.
Oh,
well, I don't know why it hasn't, right?
But like
you would basically you would go build
an end where it's like a very you build
like a very self-contained end where you
should actually be able to teach
yourself more and more stuff more and
more quickly.
Another thing that you could look at is
like
you could argue it's possible that you
actually do have it or it is
self-improvement in a sense, right? Like
because if you look at for instance, so
one thing that would be interesting to
me to look at is if you take a look at
um like Alph Go or Dota and you look at
their ELO over training, right? When you
adjust add more computing, you get a log
linear curve in ELO. But ELO is not
linear improvement, right? ELO's
exponential improvement. So if you were
to actually go track like human player
ELO over time as well, right? Like I
wouldn't be surprised that you actually
are kind of getting the expected thing.
I think like you actually might be
getting the expected improvement
and then if that is the case then it's
basically comes down to like the problem
formulation or something in non-selfplay
settings.
But we still don't have um
Yeah, read the Dota paper. I always tell
people if you read one paper, read the
Dota paper fully, including the
appendices. Read the paper
like you're crazy not to go do it.
Then he can see
you could polish up the moa.
Okay, this is quite close now to um
peak,
right? So, we can actually get some
pretty solid flops out of this.
One v one fighting game.
Yeah.
Okay. This actually goes way worse
slops, which is kind of funny. Yes. 1024
is good. What happens if we do like um
hidden size equal
128? Like what happens if we do this?
or hello bird.
That's the cutest thing. I have a little
bird just like sitting up on my
windshill.
That was nice.
Okay. So, this is where you get a big
difference right
here. Compile gives you a lot
Okay, that's a start. We have something
to run.
We keep optimizing from here,
All right. There's a restroom and then
another deadlift set and then we keep
going. Yeah.
Yeah.
a coffee.
Oh
Honestly, better than expected.
If um
if I get the third set of five, then I
can add a 10 for next week, which would
put me at uh 365,
three plates and 25s.
Not bad. Oh, not Elon. Not long.
We're working on hardcore perf
optimization as the title implies
or just directly says
Okay. So, why is this so slow? Let's
see.
it's not even supposed to be slow, is
it?
that 2.170.
And let's let's do this proper like
I got to not rip open my finger again.
Remind me next time I get up to get a
band-aid.
Oh, hey. This is
Oh, a third of the speed.
There is still only fish as well. Uh I
will be merging in more of those PRs. So
if you guys are looking for something
fun to do for a bit, little bit of RL,
go submit a fish to only fish.
Holy moly, that's a lot of SPS.
That means it's uh skipping the entire
operation though.
Oh.
See
There we go.
What this is
skips entire op.
Let me make sure it's not something
weird.
Okay. So, this doesn't change yet,
right?
Okay,
this is also not what we were expecting.
What is wrong with this thing?
Now, this is exactly what's expected,
which is 3x.
And we do like this one.
See if it's still 21.
Yeah, it takes a tiny little hit. It's
good though.
Well, that's something. Why is this now
suddenly
Does this really make this big of a
difference that like this just doesn't
work without compile
except I can't do it quite this way,
right?
Yeah, I think I got to do grad function
of evaluate, right?
Con check. I am on reream. Reream starts
the broadcast to YouTube, Twitch, and X.
As far as I'm aware, there's no way to
automatically set the category through
that.
I'd have to go like for each platform
and set everything manually every damn
time.
Yep.
If anybody knows a platform I can just
use that's easier
that does let me know like set that
stuff, great. But I don't have a better
easy way to do it at the moment.
Okay. So, the main thing we needed to do
with Eval here is um
HC come in, right? And then
we're not going to need this carry
anymore actually,
right? because
we're basically just going to take uh we
do the same batch.
but we're stuck with it
for now at least.
Okay, cuz now what we have to do right
this is the tricky bit.
So instead of grad function of model
yeah so compute loss
is fine but it has to be so this is
functional Call of evaluate.
Okay. And then this is going to return
logits and values.
And then we're going to go take a look
at what we have here.
I see. So there is a little bit of extra
overhead.
Oh, I see. I'm dumb.
You no longer need functional call.
Um, what you do is you just call
evaluate. This is actually cleaner.
So you only end up needing one
functional call, which is actually
better.
Ah,
I see what happened.
Brad function
like this.
Yes. So it didn't actually get it
somehow.
Yeah, this is like same flops now as
before, right?
What end would you use for your
self-improvement experiment or would you
build something custom? It would be
something custom.
Let me think
what I would use.
I'm honestly thinking if elo base ones
are the best.
I don't think so.
You basically just need something with a
lot of room for skill expression.
It's like pretty self-contained.
Well, I'll tell you what. I'll I I will
tell you what I have uh I have for you
here that like cuz I don't have a full
answer for you. This is actually like it
would be a research question, but there
are a few M's that actually kind of do
suggest that you get self-improvement,
but not in the way that you would want.
Basically, there are Ms where the score,
like once you fully learn the task, your
score just goes up very quickly, like
enduro and stuff like that, you get
pretty much like a linear straight up
learning curve. And then there's stuff
like Tetris or whatever where basically
once you start figuring it out, you can
get an exponential learning curve. Uh
even though for humans, you don't really
get the same like it learns faster than
humans in that sense like asmtoically.
Uh so there are Ms where
we have like uh evidence that you can
just learn really really quickly once
you start catching on. I think that the
thing that's probably missing is having
a setting that has like a high enough
skill ceiling like that, right? So like
um
if you were able to do this in like net
hack or like a really hard task where
you get this just exponential once you
start solving you just full solve or
whatever but you have to think really
hard about the task and whether that's
even possible I suppose. Um yeah
it's a hard thing.
It's a hard thing.
I might want to add a few more plots to
constellation, you know, like I might
want to add like some optional extra
stuff. We'll see
because I think what's important is to
keep track of um the shape of learning
curves over time.
You know, I had this thing with neural
MMO where in earlier versions you got
these like plateaus and then it would
like catch on and then plateau and catch
on or whatever. And then with the new
algorithm, it just like catches on and
it's nice log linear. Changes in shape
like that are important.
Oh, the other thing that's useful, Jess,
would be like
having a a pretty dang long horizon end
where
basically just having a very long
horizon end where you kind of need to
get to the end, like get to as far as
you can and then practice that little
section over and over and over. and it's
hard because you have to get all the way
back to that section to get your one
practice attempt in. An M like that
would also be useful because there's uh
there's some algorithmic stuff around
that that I think could have better
asymtoic uh perf if we were to implement
that's kind of related.
Yeah. Best answer I have off the top of
my
maybe
I'm too bad at chess to think about that
properly.
Yeah, something like that.
would be decent.
freaking compile times.
E god.
You're peaceful on the board, the more
valuable they become. Yeah.
Oh, so probably you can do something
with Yes.
Could a 10 set? Yeah. Why is it doing
CUDA 10
I mean that seems
If I can get this to work though, All
right.
Is this even like
remotely mature?
super
[Music]
Uh, I really don't know enough to be
honest, but I would probably just like
the only thing that you could really
like, okay, there's like polish and
stuff that you could obviously do that's
missing, right? But the thing is I'd
probably just do
I'd probably just do something
dramatically lower level, right?
just basically like have a bunch of good
kernels and have it be like dramatically
more manual, dramatically more control.
But you just basically you have a bunch
of fast kernels, you have a good way of
figuring out quickly which ones to use
for your machine, which is what this
thing is doing, but instead of over the
whole net, you know, you do it more like
individual kernel level. Um,
I basically just do I just shift
everything lower level
cuz honestly what I'm doing right now as
a dev, this feels [ __ ] terrible,
right? This just feels terrible.
Okay, let's try something here. I want
to try the uh the corresponding jacks
just to see.
Funny thing I wrote start a script that
set up boiler plate may not see make
fault in RAM pipe your input contain
function.
Yeah, just doing hot reloads basically
like a super jank way.
and almost nothing. And
wait, what? Do almost nothing. Hope it's
the best.
Yeah. Yeah,
it's gotten better. This is At least
this is just me fighting framework
stuff.
have written it and see I could do
something like I rewrote it and see yeah
now there you can still submit to only
fish.
All right. Do we think rock can port
this thing to Jax just as a test?
I want to see if it can.
I'm not saying we're doing jacks. I just
want to see if it's as much of a hell as
it like if the hell is as bad over there
as it is here.
cuz basically, so here's the problem,
guys. I don't know what to do with this.
And this is the thing that I was worried
about. Um,
so first of all, this [ __ ] is just like
ignoring this entire loop. So, I guess I
can technically do Let's do this first.
Let's do this first. We'll just do like
carry
and we'll just do like
we'll see if that runs. Let me get my uh
my deadlift set in. There's a restroom.
and get my deadlift set in and we will
see.
The thing is I think it's a really bad
move to have to do [ __ ] in jacks and I
only want to do that if it's like
absolutely freaking mandatory and
if I can make it not suck. I would way
way way rather just figure out like a
nice like relatively clean way to get
clever with torch compile and call that
a day. But like
[ __ ] is not easy.
like the GPU has gets a certain number
of flops. I want all my flops out of my
GPU. I don't want 1% of the flops out of
the GPU.
That might be all the deadlifts for
today. We will see if I do more sets,
but that's at least three sets of five.
Yeah. Okay. So, this [ __ ] thing
here, right, is just completely screwing
up and it's like ignoring the graph.
Enough.
repost got almost as much uh engagement
as the original thing and his account is
how much bigger than mine? 5x
Not bad.
What's this code look like? First of
all,
this actually looks like relatively sane
code.
Okay.
So
this compiled but
we know at least we can get the eager
mode uh up.
Yeah. So actually it's compiled
train loop is
as slow as um Pyth PyTorch's eager mode.
So let's just do
here. We'll do this compile
Wait, what? Burns, what do you mean in
this? Like what do you mean?
This is a graph breaking it still
actually.
Oh, well,
I
I'm honestly not really interested in
investing much in like more LLM workflow
[ __ ]
I honestly don't even know if let's say
by GPT6 or whatever. I still don't know
if I'm going to be interested in that.
Like,
Okay. So, this is like just slower,
right?
So, this is basically what um what I
keep seeing, right, is that like Jax is
not magically faster and it kind of just
sucks whenever I throw stuff like this
at it.
Okay, it's going to write me a new
version. Huh?
Four and two.
I go back to compile puffer.
What if I don't do max autotune and I
just do full graph?
Yeah. So, this is slightly slower. I
will admit the code isn't terrible, but
like there's no point if and like, oh,
we compile everything if it's going to
be
like slightly slower.
Like what the heck is this comp like
compile function even doing, right?
Like this is what the scan stuff is for,
right? Because it's the same freaking
graph
does nothing.
Does literally nothing.
Let's see if I can just get any version
of this [ __ ] to like
Yeah, you compile fast, but you don't do
anything, right?
There should just be a way to explicitly
define the freaking static graph now.
How do the graphs work? Anyways,
so it just is building up like um all
the operations that you do, right? It's
like constructing a graph out of the
operations you just every operation you
do is a node
and then backwards. It turns out you can
do um just by chain rule, right?
Gradients you only need to know each
layer. you only need to know input the
function and the output and you can
compute the gradients. So going forward
is obvious and then backwards is partial
derivatives
um at each layer.
So you're just going through a graph
forwards and then backwards.
Well, then why don't we just do uh
we do like forward
Okay,
this is something.
What application? This is puffer lib.
This is the high performance
reinforcement learning library that I
developed. It's open source. All the
demos are here. I am working on some
very heavy performance optimizations for
the next version. I'm uh I'm essentially
fighting to
I'm fighting torch because I'm trying to
make really small networks fast and that
requires optimizations that you normally
wouldn't think of.
That's completely jank, but let's see if
it works.
AJ start coding? It depends how
seriously.
Somewhere between like
12 and 14 probably.
If you mean by what age could I write
something that wasn't like complete and
utter garbage like 17, 18.
Okay. So this is this is fine, right? We
do this.
Okay. And then now
1.1 1.5 right.
I preemptively
answered that preemptively.
No, I'm good today. I was tired
yesterday, but I'm good today.
Okay, this is comparable, right?
That's very comparable.
Ah okay. So this does
this does actually compile now which is
chill.
improve larger models. Uh this will all
this will improve all models chest but
it's to differing extents.
I make money out of this. So, Puffer is
a private lab. Our stuff is free and
open source, but um companies can pay us
or as we have on the site. There's
priority service. We do custom sims. We
do um contracted R&D and larger projects
as well.
Yeah, it's better to not even start
entertaining the AI ethics stuff because
not because there aren't meaningful
questions you can ask, but because like
they're some of the dumbest people you
will ever meet in that space.
Like, you literally have to see it to
believe it.
Like I distinctly remember sitting down
at uh a dinner one time in SF and some
guy unironically trying to like pitch
shrimp welfare.
It's like well there are a lot of shrimp
so if each shrimp shuff suffers a little
bit then that's a lot of suffering.
How can it by improve how can it improve
large son of liberty? This is just pure
perf optimization. This is just like
pure run the model faster.
Let me see just I can solve my own
problem in the meantime with this.
it possibly It can't possibly be that
fast, right?
they already improved.
Okay, so this is not how research works.
Okay, you don't just you don't take
literally the most stable, best tested
chunk of architecture, write a couple of
papers, and then say, "Oh, it's better
in all applications."
it takes a lot more than that. Um, that
said, I am going to be looking at XLSTM
purely because it is it will play nicer
with compile,
but I'm expecting it to be a pain in the
ass because research is never ever as
clean as it's written on paper like
that.
There's a thing that you can do for um
for normal usage.
I I think the only motivation though
would be that it could play nicer with
compile.
That's basically it.
I'm going to I'm not joking. Like
the reason that you don't talk, the
reason that you don't start the AI
ethics thing isn't because of the
content of like the topic, right? It's
because you're going to be talking to
like the most autistic, outofouch,
insufferable people you have ever met
that like
I don't know what they think that they
are, but it's nuts. Like it's
unbelievably insane.
It's like you see some [ __ ] mess up like
that and it's just like run, get out
now.
Like I
like autism and like social ineptitude
doesn't even come close to being enough
to explain it. It has to be like that
like really really socially inept people
way more than me. I was the nerdy guy
growing up too. All right. Like really
really inept people and then like [ __ ]
tons of hallucinogens until they fried
their brain. That's the only thing I can
possibly think of. Oh yeah. And then in
the biggest echo chamber ever. That's
the only thing I could possibly think of
for how like the [ __ ] that I've seen
there.
Oh.
programming, making projects.
Don't ask me for like standard
employment advice. My stuff is very
unconventional.
If you want to know if you want to know
how to get good at the stuff that I do,
that's another story, but that's a
completely different question.
I put out plenty of educational material
on programming, ML, and RL specifically,
but I am not the like how to get a I'm
not the how to get an average job guy.
man like this stream here is mostly my
replacement for that
that and the open source community. I
have a few folks that I chat with every
so often.
um like you know that I know from AI
that I that I speak with
but this is
yeah it's tough to find those people
especially nowadays.
All right. Why the hell are my grads
zero?
I also don't particularly want to have
deep conversations about stuff that's
not like the tech I'm working on
anymore. Frankly,
like most of the people in SF suffer
more from too much thinking than from
too little.
Why the hell is this zero? Oh, is it? If
I'm this dumb, then I deserve it.
Wait, unless Hang on. I might still be
this dumb.
Well, it's not that. It's I didn't
understand how torch buffers work to be
fair.
Everyone come up with own models.
Trying to get that. Uh, there really
aren't good architecture papers in RL
though is the thing.
There really aren't.
Yeah, but just the crazy thing about
that. Okay. Like I am on a farm in the
middle of nowhere
in a warehouse with gym equipment and
servers.
So if I am more in touch than you, that
is a serious serious problem.
Welcome to all the YouTube folks. We got
a good number today. So to reiterate
what I'm doing here, um I am attempting
to torch compile an entire training loop
like multiple gradient step updates and
I'm computing uh model flops utilization
and I'm basically trying to see how good
we can get a small model uh how fast I
can get a small model to run with the
idea that I'm going to use this to like
massively improve the speed of puffer
lib overall.
And torch compile is really not designed
for this initially. Jax more so is. But
then whenever I've tried to write
comparable tests in Jax, it's easier to
get the test the test to run, but it's
not actually fast. Plus, I'd rather keep
torch if I possibly can. Just a better
library in general. Um, so yeah, that's
where I'm at.
Touch grass. I do touch grass in the
literal sense only. Why not you rest
sometime? I do rest.
I have a screwed up I have a a kind of a
screwed up idea of rest, but I do rest.
Last couple weeks, I literally have just
lifted weights all day on Sunday. It's
been good.
like I my folks were here. So, um you
know, I did a bench session with my dad,
had breakfast. Uh I went outside and
like lifted uh I got a bunch of big
boulders outside, so I moved those
around a bunch. Uh and then I came back,
I did a ton of cable work, M stuff, and
just like bunch a bunch of stuff all
day. Listen to audio books. Just chill.
500k.
I don't think 500k 500k for carpole is
not impressive at all.
And you're going the wrong way as well.
Like the expectation is that you're
going to have bigger the expectation at
least is going to be that you will have
bigger nets for smaller number of steps.
We have some decent empirical data for
that as well.
All right. Why is my grad zero?
Why is my grad zero?
This is a good time to mention uh all my
dev on Puffer. It's open source is here
at puffer.ai.
The GitHub if you want to help me out a
lot. It's free. This really helps me be
able to spend more time on this. Uh
Discord if you want to get involved with
dev. We have a ton of helpful people in
here. It's a lot easier to start on this
than you'd think. You really don't even
need much knowledge of AI, at least when
you start. If you have a decent enough
programming background, you're good to
go. You can also follow me on X for more
content. We're doing a kind of a funny
little uh community event as well. This
week, this is onlyfish.ai.
You can uh submit puffers to appear on
this website. We've got a little tool
kit. It's super easy to get started with
these. So, fun little first project in
RL. I'm going to merge a few of these in
later today or tomorrow.
The goal is to have a whole bunch of
different fish that play around
differently.
Nope. Just just a coincidence.
Well, it's not even so much a
coincidence as much as like it's got to
be a weekday and I typically make I
typically make Saturday my long work day
and I need a break after that, right?
Like I couldn't I couldn't have Sunday
be my long work day um
and then like go straight into a full
week of work after that.
All right. So, uh, for some reason this
is zero.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I see it.
Okay. That's annoying. I see why it's
smooth messed up, though.
Yeah, it doesn't need as much computing
power. Some of it definitely doesn't.
RL's kind of awesome for that, right?
Like the number of problems we can solve
in RL with models that run on a potato.
Um, it's pretty impressive. Now, the
problem, right, is RL is not as mature
of a field. RL has not had the type of
investment that uh the rest of AI has,
and it's actually kind of just a comedy
of errors. I have some articles on this
on my X tab um like my X articles tab,
but pretty much there's no good reason
why RL should be as unpolished as it is
today other than that we just completely
messed up the engineering.
So that's what I'm doing now is I'm
fixing that. And we've made a huge
amount of progress in the last year and
a half. Um, I'm working on this next
update. If I can get these PF
enhancements plus the visualizations and
stuff from the rest of this uh this
planned update working, we should have
the field in a really really good spot
just on pure iteration speed.
And we'll also have uh the tools to ask
the type of large scale scientific
questions that we've always wanted to
ask as well.
It's honestly already to the point now
when when I try to solve a new problem
with RL, most of the time when it's
like, oh, the RL is not working, it's
because I have a bug in the simulator.
Pretty much any relatively basic problem
that I build a custom sim for, the RL
more or less just works out of the box.
Done some bootstrapping. Uh, nothing
super major, Jess. Nothing super major
yet. There's a restroom real quick and
then I will keep going on this. I know
what's wrong with this code though. Um,
[Music]
do I do more deadlift sets
or do I start on something else?
I think three three heavy uh sets of
five is pretty good for today.
I think I will do let's do some weighted
pulls.
Yeah, let's do like some weighted pulls.
I'll be right back and then we will
we'll get this working and then
hopefully we can get some reasonable
compile speeds from this.
right.
45 for seven. Not bad.
It's cool stuff.
You should look up the um
like the paper on solving Atari with six
six neurons.
Need to come up with a reward function
to make a pull request or recommit. So
what you would do is it doesn't just
have to be a reward function, but that's
like the most obvious thing to start
with. You can change any aspect of
training that you like as long as you
keep the observation and the action
spaces.
Uh and then the network arc architecture
but that means like the training
curriculum like details of how the sim
runs during train um hypers you can
change a bunch of stuff and then you
just commit me the model. So, it's
essentially it's just a playground for
you to have some fun making uh an agent
that's like cool to play with
and then other people get to play with
the puffer online.
We're doing the freaking heavy ass lift
today.
I guess those are probably like the two
most tiring things I do at the moment
other than uh well since I'm not
squatting, right?
Times it's 350. Yeah. So, I think we'll
just aim for the three sets of
deadlifts, three sets of weighted pulls,
and then uh
some accessory,
and we'll get this done.
start debugging this. I know what's
wrong with it. It's the way we're doing
these buffers here.
I want to make a fish then make a fish
and PR it a bit of or
it's the same thing boxing
but like if you deal with it in the
environment then like I can throw my
default deaths at it and not have
problems. S if I'm looking at it from
the perspective of do I want to make
this end of a pain in the ass to deal
with uh just do it in the end easier.
Do make a fish
only fish
grinding harden some idea. Same here,
man.
I wanted only fins,
but it's a Finnish dating site.
You backed off the edge a little bit,
did I?
Or the.com was
I think I checked the.ai as well.
Wait, did I get the wrong domain? Hang
on.
Unless I bought it and then forgot.
I don't think I did, though.
for Manning.
What?
Chris Manning or what?
Or am I thinking of something else?
Chris Manning is a professor.
Banning publications. What the [ __ ] is
this going to be? Some
Is this Chris Manning or is it
unrelated?
When you said Manning, I thought it was
either going to be the NLP thing or like
You know, some cringe how to be alpha
thing.
Yay, we have grads.
Now I get to see if I actually need the
uh the nrad
because I don't think you do, right?
Because I think it computes buffers
separate.
Oh, you do. That's weird.
Interesting.
Yeah, it does zero grads.
That's annoying.
What did you make of this since last
year? Oh man, a ton.
Massive freaking amount. Are you kidding
me?
It's not the same field since last year
with what we've done since then.
We've got RL up to 3 million steps per
second. We've got a nice big library of
ends. We've got it so stable and
consistent that if you make any new like
relatively simple ends, it has a decent
shot of working out of the box. If it
doesn't, you run a hyperparameter sweep
and then it almost certainly just works.
Um, we've made like triple I think
progress on the harder environments that
we have so far. We've simplified stuff a
ton.
We have like fundamental algorithmic
advancements
and we've done a massive massive amount.
The project has grown like since
November like at least 5x since then.
And we have Kung here who is submitting
us uh useful PRs.
Uh, I'm going to trust you and insta
merge this, Kyouong. I'm going to take a
quick look, but insta merge
because I'm on a I'm on track here with
the new [ __ ] I'm doing.
Actually, let me read your description
first. Sweep error. Okay. Final eval.
Yep.
Failure. Cool. Refactor down sample
removed ABC. Very good.
Did you do hard stop at
Okay, that's cool.
Actually, sort of what I was thinking.
Good.
Thank you very much.
Looks good. Thank you.
Yeah, Kyouong. I'm fighting Torch
Compile right now. This is the uh the
shot cavalry work.
that like or is that just the dumbest
possible take?
Don't make your code fast because
hardware gets faster.
Lab shifting to RL.
Wait, did I say lab shifting? I said
shifting away from RL, didn't I?
I said that it's like the most likely
next bet if they're wrong, right?
I didn't say that they're going to
recognize that anytime soon, though.
Funny enough, it turns out that since I
wrote that, they started throwing RL on
their language models as well.
labs have not shifted to RL since last
year, like actual RL. They're doing like
stupid language model RL.
So far, I have not seen a single useful
innovation come out of LLMRL that
applies more broadly Were they right?
No, they weren't right. Like literally
they they literally stopped doing what
they were doing and like started doing
RL even on their language models, right?
And it's like they still haven't solved
everything like that. They've had many
billions of dollars poured in since
then. crazy crazy valuations
and we're still solving crazy [ __ ] that
they can't do with like 100k params.
I could literally do anything I want
within two months.
I could be working on optimizing the
hell out of like large language model
training pipelines within two months.
like being good at general ML, having
some domain knowledge that's pretty easy
to get
um being very good at programming in
low-level dev.
Do what you like. The skills are pretty
general.
I'm not the person to ask about like
traditional jobs either.
It's not that the LLM RL is bad. It's
just that like it's kind of subsumed the
whole like whole discussion on all of RL
and it's like it's basically stupid baby
mode RL that's just being scaled
massively on a really valuable app
which is the annoying bit to me
making a perception machine more or less
what
like lowlevel's kind of the core of a
lot of this.
It's way harder in my mind at least.
It's way harder to be a good programmer
than it is to be a good researcher.
Like research is relatively not that
difficult.
And like you're relying on your
programming skills for all of it
anyways.
A lot of academia is just like bumbling
around because of inadequate programming
skill.
All right, the compile function is still
insanely slow.
Have much ML or RL. Well, check my
guide, right? I have a guide on X that
literally just walks you through step by
step how to get into RL with projects
terminate at frequency
I don't know what you're saying mutual
yeah being a good programmer is very
very hard.
Very very hard
cuz like honestly programming is as
close as it gets to just pure thinking
and logic in my mind.
It's not like mathematics where they're
you don't have like you don't
necessarily have mental models and
abstractions always like a lot of being
a good programmer is ripping out the
abstractions.
I know in my mind like programming is
very very close to just thinking.
Okay, this compile function is like
obscenely freaking slow
is obnoxious.
Um, hang on.
What speed up would justify the compile
crap? Well, it depends, right? depends
on uh if it doesn't mess up with if it
doesn't mess up the puffer lip code,
right? And it's just really hard then
like if I get a 20 or 30% that's
actually worth it. I think I can get
much more than that.
What's this?
If we do this.
Okay. So now we have
approximate parody.
That doesn't do anything. That breaks
it.
Why is torch so slow?
Uh what are you looking at in terms of
the compile times or the flops?
It's slow in compile times because I
don't know something stupid. uh it's
slow in terms of flops because these are
small models and it's kind of tough to
optimize small models and also I'm using
a very small test because the compile
times are so Oh,
[Music]
There should not be that much seed
instability.
That much seed instability is kind of an
artifact of earlier shittier algorithms
for the most part.
And we do um we also so what we do is we
run large sweeps, right? So we run large
sweeps and then we will re-evaluate the
uh the final hyperparameters and if that
gets about the same score as the
original sweep then it's good.
Tiny looks very cool. Uh it's going to
take them he says it's going to take
them a couple years though before it's
uh perf like similar on Nvidia hardware
with torch.
Nope. Don't change the model
architecture. Makes a pain in the ass to
deploy.
There's much more interesting stuff to
play with than that though, trust me.
One off 20.6.
Very nice.
It's getting to be right. CUDA colonels
yourself a clock, but I don't want to
write autograded myself a clock.
It can see the cursor boxing. You can
have it play with the cursor. You can
like have it do tons of stuff.
It can see stars. It can see other
puffers.
Make a fish that's fun to play with and
watch.
You will be judged on whether the fish
is fun to play with.
is still compiling.
You got to be kidding me.
Um,
so here's the thing with Go.
The thing with Go
is they use search, right? And they had
a very optimized GPU implementation of
search
and I presumably of the game. So like
Alph Go is actually the one project
where like the engineering is relatively
well not straightforward because
implementing search efficiently is very
hard but it the engineering was done
quite well.
Uh and that's actually kind of hard to
do.
We're doing chess at the moment. Jess is
doing chess and my hope is that we're
going to get like a a pretty decent no
search agent that you can just train
fast with puffer.
We shall see.
MCTS so complicated. Try to implement it
fast and you'll see.
Try to implement it fast for neural nets
and you'll see.
Oh,
462 438.
So, that actually made a pretty dang big
difference,
right?
No, that was double the perf from uh max
autotune versus from
uh nothing like from regular compile. So
from compile overall we're getting more.
Yeah. So from Kyle that's 3x and 10x
in inference and in train.
But the compile times are really
obnoxious.
But this is still not good, right? These
are still very low flops numbers.
like five. The best we have here is 5%.
Not even 5% utilization.
ass.
Oh, but you know what?
No, this is going to work. This works.
Yeah, this is fine.
Okay. So, you really don't lose very
much with the um
the funk API.
You lose a little bit with the funk API,
but not very much.
Make sure there's not a
[ __ ]
Well, that makes no freaking sense,
right?
4.72.
The best
I'm just seeing if there's um additional
speed benefit from this.
eval can definitely go to be float
anyways, right?
I will say that at the very least
this is not terrible, right? Like the
what I've come up with here like this is
still good code.
The grab function thing is very slightly
obnoxious, but it's really not that bad.
I have chickens outside my window
wandering around.
compiling longer seek does take way
longer.
it's so right now it's they're two
different problems, right? The speed of
the compiled model and the speed of
compilation.
uh essentially yeah this tells us that
there's nothing to be gained by making
the seek length longer
which is good to know.
So, basically, we've gotten
we've squeezed as much of this as we
possibly can.
Why the [ __ ] does that add so much
overhead?
Tell me that's not cursed.
Tell me that's not like completely
cursed.
What are you drinking?
Lollipop.
It's like a seven out of 10 soda. That's
not bad for you.
And doesn't have sweeteners that kill my
stomach. Okay. Okay, I think this is
just difference, isn't it? finding
different kernels.
Oh, that's what it was anyways. Okay.
So, we'll do this.
Oh, that's a big difference from this
freaking stack, isn't
Can you do this? No, this is invalid,
right?
what we expect anyways.
Okay. 3.8.
If I go to like
I want to see how far I have to go
before it's optimal.
How are we going to train chess for that
search?
You just train um train a neural net to
play against itself.
Same as you do anything else.
Okay, so that's 38 T flops.
And then
if we do like this size net, which is
probably about the most we would do
Okay. So, that's about half of what we
want.
The heck is this
weird?
doesn't seem like it plays nice with
torch compile.
No difference.
Here's a restroom real quick. One more
set as well.
We're making progress. We're making
progress, but it's slow. Very slow
progress.
That is
six heavy sets for today.
It'll be just accessory work after
dinner.
fixed environment.
Well, then just like port your reward
over and retrain it.
Okay, there we go. Six.
That's nice.
38.
Okay. So, I mean this is like we have
some inference speeds here. Yeah.
Okay. So, that you still do get perf
improvements from larger and larger.
46 to 38. They still got some perf
enhancement.
That helps compile time a lot.
Maybe we can do this regional
compilation thing.
Well, yeah. One cool thing you could
technically do, right, is you could like
change the rules of chess and you could
measure ELO curves over time and
basically see if you can change if you
can find a rule modification to chess
that actually um increases the skill
ceiling of the game. That'd be pretty
cool.
960. That's funny.
Um,
I actually don't know what that does.
and replace it with inference mode in
the entire
What do you mean in the entire library?
I'm writing a I'm just what I'm
basically doing is I'm writing a
standalone compile test that's like
pretty close to the puffer setup and
trying to get optimal flops.
This guy.
All
This is kind of weird. I can't tell why
this uh this does not compile.
PhD defense. Welcome.
This is fighting torch compile.
We are fighting torch compile. That is
what we are doing today.
We got um inference for a very small
model with very small batch up to like
six T flops
and up to like 40 with a reasonable
batch size.
And now I'm trying to figure out what
the heck is wrong with um
what's wrong with this compile function
basically. time.
There we go.
Okay, let's just let's go from here,
right?
Okay, that's slightly better. Right.
So now we have the inner bit compiled,
right?
The grad function.
So if I do 64 here,
one loop, this should be fast. Yes,
the model should be compiled.
Yes.
And now if I start increasing loops,
Dude, what the hell's wrong with this
thing?
Compile times are just so unexcusably
bad.
Inexcusably bad.
So wait, you're compiling
compile the whole model as well, right?
Oh, I know why.
I know why.
That's why
we're going to make this work
cuz this is just so incredibly
obnoxious.
You know,
I got 15 minutes before dinner. We're
going to get something good.
It makes me happy when um
it makes me happy when I make a tech
take and then I get people disagreeing
with me whose code I've read and I know
is terrible.
but like there are actually people
that have like almost a perfectly
negative correlated signal. Like I don't
know. I know a handful of these people
where like basically if whenever they
say something you do the opposite like
it's actually a pretty good model at
least in like a specific area.
I can think of like five or so off the
top of my head.
That's funny. It's basically that but
for engineering.
The Python typin thing is so incredibly
stupid.
Like literally use any other language.
It's like the only good thing about
Python.
Is this thing just stuck?
Well, here. I think this will work
better now anyways.
Use Python to bind Jacks to what?
That doesn't make any sense.
that's a good question. Does Jax have a
a non-Python
back end?
Jack is written entirely in Python.
Lovely.
Where's the video pin?
And I got to get you your docs as well.
Welcome all.
I'm excited for this.
Where's the video, Finn?
Some of the models only seem to work in
Jacks.
No, that's not true.
I tried the Jax versions work, but
they're like not fast. Like, they're as
slow as PieTorch eager mode. Not flying,
though. Okay,
you got me all excited there. Come on,
man. Let's see. Let's see the puffer
drone. Here,
we can make we can make only drones.ai
next where we have a bunch of drones
that fly around. Oh, yeah. For if for
anybody who hasn't seen this, this is uh
only fish.
You can submit a puffer to the tank
and then you can play with them.
All puffers that get submitted go to the
website.
Very close. That's good to hear. I am
suffering through torch compile
optimizations.
So, I'm glad that you're having some fun
Jax is not a lot faster from anything
that I have timed.
It's a lot easier to get the comp the
Jack's compilation to work with stuff
like this, but then it's like still
slow, so what's the point?
Dang.
Well, this will be the uh the project
for later today, I suppose, for the
evening, cuz we got the uh we got the
forward pass at a decent speed. Now,
it's just up to me to get the the
backwards pass. But this is still good
progress.
I'm going to go get myself dinner in a
second here. Um, for folks watching
though,
I will be back in probably 45
minutesish.
Medium length dinner today.
Uh, if you're interested in all of this
generally,
this is all going into the next update.
The goal is to have much much much
faster
uh, training, faster sweeps, faster
everything.
It's all on puffer.ai. It's all open
source. Start the GitHub. It's free. It
actually helps me out more than you'd
expect.
Uh, everybody is on the Discord. This is
where all the dev happens if you want to
get involved. And you can follow me on X
for more content, including my
educational articles and my research
posts.
I will be back right after I get some
food because I am starving. I'm hoping
that we get at least uh a full prototype
of this done today that like has a
reasonable speed and that I can be happy
with like the end to end thing that if I
maintain most of this speed, we should
be able to break like 10 mill steps per
second. That I'd be happy with. All
right, back